[Music]
foreign
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Piers Morgan on says that
Harry and Megan were booted out of
Frogmore Cottage just 24 hours after
Harry published his kiss and tell books
Fair has the king finally got to grips
with the Rogue Royals will he now
abandon from the coronation II and
stripped them with their titles
the lockdown files seek more pressure on
disgrace Matt Hancock as he angrily
denies planes made by Isabel oakshot on
this show last night tonight she's back
with more Revelations including what
Hancock and the care Minister Helen
Whitley said about me when I left Good
Morning Britain and when I had a covid
test plus a spade of protests erupt in
London over drag queen performances to
Children there's 15 U.S states consider
laws to quash the Queens our drag art is
really harmful to kids we'll debate
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
well good evening for London welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensored Harry and Megan
the currently the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex famously gushed about their love
of chickens in one of the more
saccharine moments of their Oprah
Winfrey SOB Fest well the chickens are
now coming home to roost for these two
the royal family kept the stoic silence
as The Poisoned darts rained down from
their Californian pedestal but King
Charles is quietly and devastatingly
taking charge now we now know that he
booted a couple out of their palatial
Frogmore Cottage just 24 hours after
Harry's book spare or spare me as I call
it was published we also now know that
Harry and Mega's popularity is crated on
both sides of the Atlantic with polls
showing even prince Andrew is now more
popular than they are in America as well
as now being offered the keys to their
house
and we also know that in America where
they've strained every sinew to become
much loved celebrities that are actually
viewed like this
so let me start with you Sam you've
lived a life with the royal family
you've had everything handed to you but
you say your life has been hard and now
you've written all about it in your new
book where
yes that's right fans you see my wife
and I are totally like you should write
a book because your family like stupid
and then so are like journalists
there's not a clear divider they're all
family the workers and the shirkers the
heavy lifters and the grifters The
Prince and Princess of Wales literally
Welsh guards yesterday it's in Davis Day
Parade Camilla the queen consort
recovering from a reason about a covid
with promoting children's literature
King Charles is preparing to make State
visits to Germany and France and his
first world tour is Monarch like a
Markle meanwhile made a state visit to a
coffee shop which sells superfood lattes
inspired by holistic ingredients from
around the world and Prince Harry had
another outing on us late night
television The Leftovers of a previous
interview taped on his self pity tour
Harry
what is the best sandwich
I would say a cheese and ham toasty with
Dijon mustard on top
toasty means grilled okay there you go
unbelievable guys sick thin line to the
throne on Saturday he's out of the game
vlogging tickets to a digital seminar
family trauma his trauma from his 13
million dollar Californian mansion
uh you have to pay 33 by the way to tune
in online
to see him banging on about his trauma
again and what a victim he is and how
it's also beastly and unfair that he's
making hundreds of millions fleecing his
Royal titles without doing any world
Duty for it but that's his level Now
isn't it for Harry a gossiping gutter
snipe selling out his family to the
highest bidders a wannabe reality star
but that star is fading fast Harry and
Megan think they can carry on having
their Royal cake and eating him
using those Royal titles I could say
while abusing the institution that
afforded them those titles and as usual
I'm afraid they're wrong and King
Charles is right to draw the curtain on
Miss ludicrous soap opera on May the 6th
the King has his coronation it will be
one of the most important moments in
modern British history and the very last
thing we need or want are the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex current titles rocking
up with their camera Crews to distract
attention and get more material for
their next Act of money grabbing
betrayal next week 2 000 invitations
will be sent out in live view it's time
for Charles to be firm and make sure
they're not on that list well joining me
now is the sun wrong auditor Matt
Wilkinson political journalist Ava
Santina plus an authoring columnist
Maureen caliber welcome to all of you
let me start with you Matt great scoop I
mean this was a proper eye-popping scoop
particularly now that we know that the
order to evict Harry and Megan from
Frogmore Cottage came from King Charles
within 24 hours of the launch of spare
back on January the 10th yeah no it's
astonishing I mean Charles I see he's
acted very quickly very decisively and
particularly it was so close to a spec
so close to after spare and he's seen
the the family's traumas the family
splits everything that's happened with
Megan and Harry and Andrew that kind of
poisoned the last three or four years of
of the Queen's Reign sadly and you could
say that Charles has finally by kicking
them out of Frogmore he's kind of
finally delivered makes it no I don't
suppose you'll lose my sleep over Meghan
Markle
um disappearing at a far more College he
probably will lose some sleep over this
action in relation to his son because
he's his son it's very sad that he's got
to this stage isn't it really I mean
we're always told and he has shown as
well that we're always told that he
dearly loves his son and the door is
always open to his son when Harry came
over recently they came out they came
over Megan and they came over and they
met her at Clarence House and I think
it's an intense disappointment and
sadness for Charles that it has actually
got to this stage yes it's bringing
Maureen cannon from across the pond uh
over in East Hampton morning thank you
for joining is
um I was staggered last week to see a
poll that said that Megan and Harry
since the release of this book and the
Netflix documentary are now less popular
in the US than prince Andrew I mean that
was jaw-dropping
oh here's it's remarkable really uh
there's no love lost here for prince
Andrew believe me
um I think the the real sort of final
Wallop to their reputation here one that
leaves no doubt where the bulk of the
American public stands on these two was
the South Park episode so for the South
Park episode to Air and it went viral
and people could not stop talking about
it to then be followed up with this
incredibly it's a sad decision but it
feels very necessary for King Charles to
remove them to send a clear message that
what you are doing and what you are
continuing to do as you pointed out with
this Saturday's upcoming winge-a-thon
online for 33.99 with pre-vetted
questions no live comments I do believe
that's King Charles saying there are
more things we can take away from you if
you do not stop harming this family
right I completely agree well look Ava
you're in the uh well the unenviable
position of trying to defend these two
because I think pretty much everyone
else we tried to get to do it didn't
want to know I mean they've lost even
their keenness supporters are you still
standing in team Sussex no I have never
been team Sussex I've always been team
Auntie monarchy and anti-royal I don't
think that any of them actually have a
place at the top of the hierarchy in the
UK anymore I think it's outrageous that
they even had entitlements still to this
Cottage I mean when they renovated it
they charged three million pounds to the
taxpayer which I know they eventually
paid back but the idea that three
million pounds was taken away
potentially from paying nurses from
paying teachers and re-wallpapering that
Cottage well the truth about the royal
family is though the costs of
maintaining the royal family are offset
by the money they bring in oh they are
oh come on
they're offset by the money that comes
in particularly listen people comments
I have been yeah that was the hundredth
time that Arsenal have beat Everton yeah
that last night I was really quite
upsetting I just want to make sure
you're okay thank you thank you so
delicate tonight um but yeah the point
about the monarchy though is you're
wrong about that because you may not
like the idea of it that's fine but they
don't actually cost the country any
money they're a net positive they cost
the country a fortune and Prince which
dancers a lot of us Prince Charles has a
lot of his own money actually enough to
sustain himself he does not need to be
taking money off the taxpayers to live
his life you can keep telling me they
cost a lot of money they don't okay
it would come without them they would
come to see the castles it's also the
incredible good work that they do not
for their own benefit but for the
benefit of the country they don't have
to go out and work for all the do all
this wonderful work for Charities they
don't have to go out and race profile
for Charities
without getting upset I would totally
read a book today like Camilla did and
then get to live in a palace off the
back of that it's a lot harder job than
that I could have been to prisons and
read books I'll do that also every Tony
spitting cough of your private life was
just battered across the papers would
you be comfortable fine fine
[Laughter]
given I failed to even rally a tiny
Slither of support from me for the
Sussex news that's obviously the white
credible abandoned them I want to bring
in now Ernest Jones or Ernest Jones
uh I'm sorry uh Ernest Owens my I think
I do make a bum um
only me and now
well you wrote a piece last week for
Rolling Stone magazine saying uh cancel
culture is good for democracy so I'm
going to come to that ludicrous premise
in a minute uh but I also remember you
Tweeting when I uh left Good Morning
Britain uh a series of tweets calling me
a racist including enjoying how folks
keep getting Piers Morgan together for
his races to tirades against Meghan
Markle on Good Morning Britain I was
just curious could you could you
remember a single racist thing that I
said about her or have ever said about
her
well thank you for having me on Pierce I
was surprised when I found out I would
be on your show again
we take all types on it
I I well all types well there you go
um but I I think really a lot of it just
seemed to be biased I think that you was
really just harsh on um you know the
Duchess of Sussex and I think there was
a little bit of bias in the way that you
had really gone after her
I didn't ask you about that I just said
what were the racist tirades what what
racist thing I've ever said about Meghan
Markle I'm curious you you tweeted quite
a few times that I was a racist I'm just
curious what was the racism I said your
remarks I said your remarks there's
races
I think that it's biased I think that
you had a sense of bias of how you were
speaking about her and how you was
really being insensitive to her
mentorship
being biased or skeptical of some of her
claims is not the same as being racist
what was the thing I said that was wrong
I never hold on do you want the person
of color to speak or do you want to just
talk over me
sorry nothing to do with your skin color
I don't care if you're black or white
okay
try and tell me giving you tweeted to
your many followers
repeatedly you did this repeatedly you
have called me a racist repeatedly for
racist things I've said about Megan
stand by watch you Tweeting what was it
I said about Megan would you let me talk
ever that's been racist
are you gonna let me talk are you just
gonna overtalk me
that's my progression you're asking a
black person to explain how what you did
could be perceived as racist and rather
than letting me finish talking you're
over talking and be highly defensive am
I being racist again this dog is
hollering right now am I being racist
again
okay you're being dismissive can can I
actually talk or maybe because you don't
answer the question why don't you be on
the show
okay so can I answer the question yes
you can please do
okay thank you okay so your targeting of
Megan markle's mental health gaslighting
her specifically calling to question the
legitimacy of her claims about the royal
family being racist you dismissing those
claims you consistently having a sense
of badgering her and targeting her it
just felt like on my end that there was
some racial bias there now you may feel
like it's not maybe a sexism maybe it's
misogyny maybe it's a combination of
both her gender and her race but it was
perceived by thousands of people 57 000
people had called Good Morning Britain
about some of your imaginations
you act like it's just making money but
it wasn't just making it
you do have to be careful when you spew
more lies unfortunately because 57 000
were people not spewing live I'm about
to explain what you just said was wrong
a lie 57 or if you're going to give your
interview you're going to let me answer
the question 50 seven thousand go ahead
Pierce
Ernest 57 000 people complained to ofcom
the TV regulator and guess what five
months later every one of the complaints
was thrown out and oftcom found in my
favor to have my right to free speech
and freedom of expression but I come
back to my initial point about you you
repeatedly tweeted to many people that
I'm a racist and I'm simply asking you
comment earn it once
between racist comments so did I say a
racist tirade what was it
I felt like you're attacking if Morgan
Marco was racially biased oh you felt
right I believe you felt like it was
your feeling I felt that way it was your
feeling that I'm a racist was it
I felt like what you did was racially
insensitive I never said verbatim on
Twitter that you were racist I said you
made me actually you just said that
you're enjoying people together for his
racist tirades but what's he looking at
your Tweet now Ernest and there were
plenty more in fact while I'm talking to
you will dig the others up just go and
take them out folks um here's my point
Ernest the reason that people think that
I may have had a racist connotation to
my criticism of Meghan Markle it's
because people like you high profile
black people in America kept saying that
without any evidence and now I've got
you on my show I'm finally able to ask
you why did you tell those about me
you're blaming the black guy I won't
blame him the black guy i'm blaming you
as a high-profile black man for claiming
wrongly well and defensively racist and
my motivation towards my criticism of
Meghan Markle which to be clear my
criticism of her and Prince Harry is I
think they both tell lies they both
recently said they didn't mean to call
the royal family racist
you can say these things you can say
these things on Twitter when you're
actually helped to account said about
Meghan Markle you don't have any
evidence
platform than me and you've attacked
Meghan Markle and it's impacted her
mental health and I feel like someone
like me as a black person defending her
as an innocent black woman in that
situation I felt like I was standing up
for her you need to be accountable for
your impact and your power
you have a big influence and you're
trying to play a victory
and it was disrespectful no no Ernest a
modern victim and I'm not a racist are
you a victim I'm not a victim and I'm
not a racist I'm somebody who lives
let me finish speaking I I listen to the
Oprah Winfrey Show I watched it and I
identified immediately a number of lies
and I said that on air the next morning
other guests disagree with me and you
were delighted about the way they came
after me and that's fine but then you
said I was racist repeatedly that my
criticism
racially motivated you're being
intellectually dishonest you did not
just say she was a liar you question
other aspects of her mental health
aspects of it as offensive repeat what
you said I said I didn't repeat what you
said I said I didn't believe her
why because there is no evidence to
support the claims that she made she
said she went to a senior moment
was no evidence Earnest I'm about to
tell you what I said
she said she went to a senior member of
Buckingham Palace staff and said she was
feeling suicidal and that member of
Staff said she couldn't get help that
story doesn't reappear in Harry's 415
page book and has never been
substantiated by anybody else nor has it
been repeated
I'm afraid you did not know that when
you said sorry I didn't believe it it
didn't sound true and by the way why you
didn't believe that Ernest what honest
you're allowed
to disbelief I'm allowed to describe
and I'm also allowed to disbelieve you
when you call me a racist because it's
wrong and you shouldn't do it I said
that you made racist remarks I did not
call your racist peers you're trying to
make yourself a martyr in a situation
that you started you didn't have to go
disrespectful below the belt with Megan
you chose to do that
[Applause]
her character before the British press
and you know how the time
what you were doing I've been Justice
scathing if not more so against Prince
Harry who I actually think is more to
blame
didn't you I want to know if this is
true X riddle me this wasn't there a
point in time where at least you tried
to pursue a relationship with her you
are absolutely no before all of this
happening absolutely okay it's another
lie I met her once in my life
okay
okay which means okay we found more
tweets while we've been talking to you
are you calling me a British media
racist darling what does that mean
Ernest
what does that mean it means that you
have always you have recently chosen
lately in your career for whatever
reason you went the road of basically
baiting into a lot of the bias coverage
of Meghan Markle and a lot of it
happened a lot of them has been targeted
towards her in a biased way and and come
on can you admit that the coverage
around Meghan Markle has been racially
biased absolutely no I'm not talking
about your work no I think it's General
I think it's another load of absolute
hogwash nonsense so you're dismissing
the role of race in all of this you
don't think none this has a role I'm
saying the British media the British
media has never been racist about Meghan
Markle okay that's just the LIE we
disagree because we disagree it's a fact
no it's not what is a lie what is a lion
is this are you telling people
repeatedly I'm a racist and then you
can't produce any evidence other than as
your teammate a racist tirade yeah and
you're and you're and you're offended
but but here's the thing for the
criticism not offenders
nothing again you're blaming me for your
criticism it has nothing to do with your
skin color Earnest I don't care when you
love the black influential person you
name my race you said you're a black
influential person and that's why people
thought that way I think
I think when high profile black people
like you go public on Twitter sorry
black people like me like you go public
on Twitter and call me a racist
it's
been lovely catching up with you uh let
me go to to Maureen again Maureen
um one of the problems I have with this
whole
debate I guess is the way that Meghan
Markle framed all this through the prism
of racism and was supported by people
like Ernest Owens and others who who
bought into this this whole narrative
the royal family are a bunch of callous
races really striking to me that none of
the race claims reappeared in Harry's
book not only the mental health claims
none of it it was like it never happened
now he now he's been giving interviews
saying we never meant to call the Royals
racist and there you have this guy who I
don't know from Adam by the way other
than he thinks Council cultures good for
democracy which is obviously insane
um he thinks it's fine to just go on
social media and call me directly
repeatedly a racist and when I ask him
for any evidence of racism and anything
I've ever said he said it's just a
feeling he gets
uh yeah I mean it's it's really it's
it's very difficult especially if you
were as as I was also critical of Meghan
Markle pretty early on I had very much
the same reaction to the Oprah interview
that you did where multiple things that
she was saying that Harry was saying
Harry was not saying they weren't adding
up they didn't make any logical sense
the idea that Prince Harry who along
with uh Kate and William founded heads
together right a mental health advocacy
platform would be told that his wife who
is suicidal can't get help it just it it
made no sense Not only was that nonsense
but also they're like little claims like
the Archbishop of Canterbury she said
married them secretly three days before
the televised wedding that would have
been a crime and the Archbishop would
have been taken to prison
so immediately I knew this was all
nonsense she made a claim that their son
Archie wasn't going to be a prince
because of his skin color again
immediately we knew that was a complete
rubbish she didn't understand the
succession rules so all of it was to me
garbage I mean I said I wouldn't believe
her if she read a weather report but it
was ironic that the guy that calls me a
racist but can't support it just wrote a
piece of Rolling Stone last week I'm
sure you saw this saying that canceled
cultures give a democracy actually it's
the opposite it's incredibly damaging to
democracy because it's really about
feelings not facts he just feels I'm a
racist you can't actually point to
anything which is racist he just feels
it and I think that's one of the massive
problems we have in in society
I I couldn't agree with you more and you
suffered a very real world consequence
you lost your job
Under The Cloud of racism you know and
and so it's doubly gobsmacking to have
Harry on his
worldwide privacy tour right promoting
this book when he sits with Tom bradby
and says well we never said they were
racist we never said that the royal
family was racist and you're going are
you gaslighting are you just gaslighting
everybody haven't we all been laboring
under this illusion that you and your
wife have been perpetuating absolutely
by the way your grandfather's dying
absolutely unbelievable well Maureen
Maureen thank you as always for joining
me I didn't know Ernest was still with
us but thanks again Ernest I loved
catching up
um final observation to YouTube about
this
I do think that racism charge uh Matt
was incredibly damaging to the brand of
the royal family and the monarchy and
for Harry just to Simply pretend that
wasn't what they meant it honestly it
sent shockwave through the royal family
when they said that on Oprah they were
silent for about 48 hours I couldn't
raise anybody because you knew they were
just looking introspectively thinking
what on Earth where has this actually
come from and they came out with that
Infamous statement Recollections may
vary which now lives on and when you
know when he came out I spoke to people
after he spoke to I think it's Anderson
Cooper when he did the interview and
said we didn't mean it to be racism
everybody in the palace took that
original comment he made his Oprah as an
allegation of racism I mean Ava what do
you think is I mean you lend yourself to
the works I presume you can identify as
work um no come on that's silly don't
open a question but one of my big
problems with the white Brigade is this
thing about they put feelings before
facts they think it's enough to feel
these things to have a lived experience
even if it doesn't actually happen it's
what you think happened you know this
guy thought I was a racist so he just
tweeted it well look I mean I'm not
going to get into that I'm not going to
start taking part in any of that but I
think around the palace I think Megan
made a claim I don't understand why
Harry retracted on that or reneged and I
don't understand why he did I truly
believe her I still believe her now I
did actually think that a lot of the
press coverage was racist I do think it
was actually I think I think the way
that the Press went after her was not
methodical it was actually it was quite
it was quite shocking to see it was
uncouth I just there was no racism
you've got to think about what was
written in tablets you've got to think
about what was you know we're talking
about her exotic blood this and you know
it was good lying in a Rachel Johnson
piece who was
except she's not a racist so it wasn't
racially intended at all there was one
clumsy headline about Straight Out of
Compton because you've got to think
about the storm that was going around
they were the only two things that
anyone could find in the entirety of
tabloid coverage and right up to the
wedding it was unbelievably positive
unbelievably positive it wasn't positive
in Britain no you're living in clouds
you don't think it was positive it was
euphoric anyway it feels like a break
lovely to see you're staying I think
aren't you if you can get if I can keep
through it yeah no it's the Arsenal game
it really has upset me
uh great scoop thank you proper
old-fashioned eye problem
congratulations to you uh Matt Wilkinson
from the sun will still become Matt
Hancock another Matt not so impressive
it's fuming for what he calls a massive
betrayal I talked to these Isabel oh
shots he's Shameless she's unrepentant
she's back with more Revelations
including some about me
it's off the break
[Music]
foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
prime minister he isn't making the case
you're making the case here now I think
you did kill these women because they
need Justice you did kill them didn't
you
and you walked with old races we're all
sexist World home before Panda Lila
[Music]
thank you
history is littered with a long line of
lovable but Angry Men
good try
contractually my stupidity pays off I
don't believe it but one man rises above
them all what just happened
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
it's all kicking off just in the breaks
here well welcome back it's day two of
The Sensational lockdown leaks which
have power pressure on disgraceful my
health secretary Matt Hancock today's
files revealed then education secretary
Gavin Williamson the man who was fired
three times imagine how bad you've got
to be to achieve that Accolade a blasted
teacher unions for looking for excuses
not to work during the pandemic Hancock
called them Absolute asses which is
pretty ironic coming from him uh well
because I can reveal one absolute ass
Hancock and his own top team were about
me
quite a story with this first in May
I got covered symptoms and I took a
covid test and so I tweeted this to say
look until I get the results back and I
get the all clear I can't do Good
Morning Britain Hancock immediately
tweeted his team with an opportunity he
wrote them saying tempting as it is I
probably shouldn't comment on this but
if you collie's pointing out kindly that
he can only have a test because of the
ramp up of testing in the past week
would be good so beneficial for him if
you wish me well an advisor wrote you
should tweet him best wishes totally
straight wish him all the best and hope
he's okay be really classy and then get
others to point out how classy you're
being and that's exactly what Matt
Hancock did
if you test positive I sincerely hope is
mild he tweeted me publicly
and other people praised him for being
so classy
and that wasn't his intention at all
and a series of fawning Hancock
followers Julie congratulated his
commendable maturity exactly as he and
his team planned
class is tough while in March of the
following year this actually gets better
by which time Matt Hancock had presided
over one of the worst cover responses of
any of this of the wealthiest countries
in the world I've left my job at good
morning brim we just discussed that you
already know the story we've just been
debating him what I didn't know until
today is that the health secretary Mr
Hancock I'm the then social care
Minister Alan weightly during a deadly
pandemic
they saw an opportunity here as well
Helen Whiteley messaged in what's in the
WhatsApp group to Matt Hancock how about
we celebrate the departure of peers at
or after our team meeting tomorrow p.m
just a thought Hancock replied with one
word perfect
would have been wouldn't it if they'd
had a big party to celebrate me losing
my job after actually holding people
like those two do such a vigorous
account for the previous year
problem
they did have that party we don't know
lockdown restrictions at the time would
have meant that that kind of party to
celebrate me losing my job
would have been strictly prohibited
illegal and the people that made that
law would have been then
well joining me now is our very own
Isabel oakshot who got that Sensational
scoop at all TV presenter Richard Tice
who probably has known about a scoot
longer than most of us and political
journalist Ava Santina is still with us
struggling with I think is a burgeoning
cold which if you give it to me means
you won't be back on the show for at
least six calendar months
um neither will you by the looks of how
unwell she is
um
fascinating little insight just
involving me in these things not
significant by any means compared to all
the other significant stuff but
interesting into their mindset about how
they just were spinning everything and
how jubilant they were to get someone
who was calling them out on all of their
nonsense uh repeatedly getting what they
saw as is due comeuppance I mean I did a
search for your name today peers and I
have to say that um there were so many
mentions of you that I had to give up
trying to pull them all out and look
they were frankly obsessed by you
um they were continually wondering what
to say to you to keep you in the place
that they wanted you to be they were
worrying about the extent to which you
were challenging them
um you and I differed over what you
should have been challenging them on
where we did agree is that they should
be held to account and they didn't like
that and they were absolutely Overjoyed
when you left your job I also found uh
Richard that the one about Kobe I mean
at that time covid was still this is
very early on in the first wave you know
one of my good Morning Britain
colleagues Kate garraway her husband was
critically ill and remained so from
covid so it was no laughing matter for
us if somebody got covered in their 50s
at the time with no vaccine so I was
pretty concerned it turned out I didn't
have it then I did get it the following
year but
um I didn't have it when I when I feared
I might and when it was really scary you
know
um certainly I wasn't laughing about it
this was a pretty serious moment and yet
the way they reacted even to vads
pretty actually pretty callous but
that's what we know is that actually
they were they were laughing about lots
of things at a time when they had
successfully terrified the nation and in
those first few weeks everybody no one
knew what was really going on but they
seemed remarkably relaxed about it that
was sort of May 2020 and the idea that
they could be wasting time in the nicest
possible way of this thinking about you
um they should have been focusing on the
science what's the latest data what are
the right decisions to make what are we
getting right what are we getting wrong
what do we need to change they shouldn't
be focusing about any individual at all
and I just find that whole thing
throughout this process extraordinary
well I mean what we'll see in tomorrow's
Telegraph is uh the the kind of gloating
and the gleefulness with which they
reacted when people were arrested or got
into trouble with the authorities for
supposed breaches of the lockdown
restrictions they were very keen for
example to see Nigel farage punished and
even went to the extent of trying to get
the home office involved in making sure
tough question for you on this because
you you obviously come at this very
anti-lockdown perspective and you're
perfectly entitled to and lots of people
felt so my mildest son was part of that
bandwagon and remained so today but then
he's a young person doesn't see the need
for young people to have taken that
seriously my question for you though if
you were the health secretary or the
Prime Minister you're the prime minister
right you two were running the country
which God forbid could one day happen
who knows
um if you're in the country and we get
hit by a novel virus again and it was
the first time we hadn't been hit by
covet already right so it's completely
new and you see it destroying Health
Systems in Italy right on our doorstep
yeah one of the best health systems in
the world people just dying in their
thousands every day and there's no
vaccine that may not be a vaccine there
are no therapeutic drugs people are
dropping like flies we don't really know
yet that it's targeting just all people
or vulnerable people we don't really
know anything
other than a lockdown to buy time what
else would you do to stop Mass death
this actually isn't a tough question for
me because I'm not actually a Critic of
the initial lockdown I think that was
absolutely the right so the ones that
came later yeah I think subsequent
lockdowns were not justifiable as we
found out more about how this disease
worked what the mortality risks were
amongst different demographics but
absolutely I would have taken that
decision in those early days until we
worked out what this was we were
contending with imagine if it had been
ebola-like and the fatality rate no I
met one of the people involved with the
AstraZeneca uh vaccine up in Oxford and
he said to me it's like you don't want
to worry about you know covid so much
anymore but if the plague comes back
which had a 30 to 50 percent death rate
including children imagine that right so
and this is what this is what keeps
those guys uh awake at night on on code
very interesting series of things have
been bubbling out about all this we need
a proper Global look at this obviously
this certainly things like the efficacy
of masks are now being seriously
questioned in some of the reports I've
seen certainly there was a massive
u-turn on whether vaccines could prevent
transmission and I was all for punishing
people who wouldn't take it if it meant
they could still transmit it and if they
had the jab they couldn't right to the
point I was told well actually that was
a mistake so I changed my mind
um and we're now being told that it
almost certainly came from the lab and
not from the wet Market again people
that said this kind of thing at the time
and I'm not going to absolve myself from
responsibility for being censorious I
was but I was basing my my
sensoriousness on what I believe the
experts knew turned out they didn't
really know and that was the whole point
because they didn't know but they wanted
to shut down debate whether it was the
Wuhan lab you know where did it come
from The Masks I mean I had something
taken off YouTube with Mike Graham from
talk TV we shouldn't be on YouTube
because because we shouldn't be on
YouTube because we talked about masks
and there was never any evidence indeed
let's remember right at the beginning
actually our own health experts the
government's advisors were saying they
said they're pointless they're pointless
and then they changed their mind
there are still different schools of
thought but we should certainly be
examining this right Ava what's your
taking it I mean we live in a strange
world where you know this shows aren't
called uncensored and like I say I'm not
going to take myself out of the blame
game for this for being overly said I
was censorious actually because I was
acting on what I believe to be the fact
but it turned out that actually like a
lot of stuff in a fast-moving Health
crisis the facts change I think what the
leak has shown is how self-serving and
well untruthful that entire cabinet was
throughout throughout the entire Boris
Johnson Premiership I mean Matt Hancock
just seems he's come across as one of
the most two-faced fake politicians I
think that we've ever experienced the
whole thing about is test the test 100
000 tests a day I was on it was very
self-served I was on him about that
every day on good morning because I
smelt a rat yeah when he finally got
there now it turns out he got told
actually if we just send them out it
doesn't matter if they get taken that'll
count as a test the whole thing was a
wreck yeah but also like he was a little
child like he needed to hit a goal yeah
I mean that's not public health and that
goal actually disobey
the testing of people going into Care
Homes whether it was from hospitals or
staff or patients from the community
that was the impact of that and that's
incredibly serious and that was all
because of his his Target we understand
ambitious targets we all have them but
his was an absolute Obsession and he
fixed it at the end with 26 000 walking
out of an Amazon warehouse to make the
numbers when in new loads them wouldn't
be used about Matt Hancock's accused of
a massive betrayal which did make me
laugh out loud when I heard that this
morning but I mean what's been your
reaction to his reaction what I would
say is the number of messages I have got
pouring in from Ordinary People saying
thank you for doing this because we need
to know this stuff and we were never
going to get it from a public inquiry
that has no deadline the Betrayal is not
me betraying a politician and his
precious reputation the Betrayal is his
he betrayed the whole country with a
flawed response to the lockdown and I
make no apology whatsoever for putting
it in the public domain no but I do
worry about what's going to happen to
anyone who's lost someone from covid I
mean can you imagine I mean how
trivializing this this whole thing makes
it Matt's movements throughout all of
this trivializes why do people die why
do people lose their loved ones because
of the self-centered idiots I completely
agree it all looks like politics and
spin and making himself look good I have
to say that the book which you did with
him was a halliography of look at me I'm
great I cracked it everyone loves me but
now we look at the what's apps quite a
lot of Revelations in it if you you know
if you read it there was a lot to be
fair on that he did lean towards uh
Revelation where he could but it was
never going to be comprehensive it's
basically about what a hero had been
here but you remember that expression
we're following the song yes and it
turned out to be an absolute well also
it turns out never following it also
turns out that I think in a in a free
country the science should be challenged
from all sides right because there's no
such thing as the science and I will I
will never again take
in any circumstance because we learned a
hard lesson we've got to take a break um
when we come back uh protests drag
performances for children erupt in
London our drag queen's a threat to kids
what about that
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is like some kind of Submarine
prime minister he isn't making the case
you're making the case here now I think
you did kill these women because they
need Justice you did kill them didn't
you
what we're already asses we're all
sexist World home before Panda Lila
[Music]
thank you
foreign
with a long line of lovable but Angry
Men
take this anymore
I don't believe it but one man rises
above them all what just happened
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back outrage is our Optical
America's drag queens leave nightclubs
to take over libraries and schools for
drag queen story hours for kids the
events have become too controversial but
a third of U.S states are debating laws
that would make it harder to perform a
drag at all those Frontier the culture
wars has now reached Britain's Shores
the protests erupting and drag events
for kids at the tape Museum and a South
London pub well join me to discuss
always is gay rights activist pet
detachable drag artist vanity Von glow
thus the YouTuber political commentator
Lauren Chen let me start with you Lauren
so it's been a big thing in America this
why
well I think this is such a huge topic
right now because parents are frankly
Fed Up of the idea that just because
you're going to be called a bigot unless
you agree that you're supposed to be all
right with grown men wearing prosthetic
breasts performing for your children and
there's a lot of people who will say
Well they're just reading stories uh we
know for a fact that that's just not the
case there have been like videos from
these drag performances where there are
sex acts being simulated where there are
are there's nudity and there's even one
going on right now a viral video that
shows someone performing in BDSM gear
none of this is appropriate for children
this isn't a gay rights issue this is
simply what is proper for children If
This Were females performing these acts
it would still be unacceptable and
frankly I I'm not going to be scared
into silence and saying this is not all
right simply because I might offend some
people if you want to do this in your
own time with an adult audience that's
one thing but this is absolutely not
family fun okay so valency of Anglo I've
been I've been to a drag show on in West
Hollywood you can imagine what that one
was like very full-on very courageous
very funny had a great had a great night
wouldn't want my kids anywhere near it
when they were young yeah that's
understandable I work in SoHo in the
basement bars and
um I wouldn't necessarily want kids at
my show either it would restrict what
I'm able to say so should they be going
into schools or performing at events
with kids in in that kind of environment
well we need to be careful to avoid a
type of hyperbole that I think is taking
place in America you know cardi B is not
the same singer as Barbra Streisand and
the work that she does on stage is not
the same as the performance as a Barbra
Streisand in the exact same way drag is
a broad Church there's a lot of
different performance Styles and it's
not always uh this hypersexualized
stripper-esque performance that's a big
part of the drag of burlesque but
there's also a lot of drag that I find
it a little dull I wouldn't want to do
it but that's quite Disney princess
quite um Anodyne actually and that's
what's happening at the drag queen story
hours as I see it in the UK Peter it's a
problem that uh as with all these things
there are a few examples where drag
queens have simply gone too far they get
caught on camera that becomes the
narrative and some something we moved to
quite a puritanical response I mean for
example when you go to Panther at
Christmas there's normally someone in
Drag and everyone's laughing and the
place is full of kids so I don't think
necessarily it is always harmful it to
be in a children environment but it does
depend what they're doing and some of
these clips I've seen have been I think
crossing a line well certainly here in
Britain the drag story time is very much
about encouraging young people to read
it's about using drag as a way to engage
people do we have to do that well it
makes it more fun for kids to have this
character dressed up all glamorous and
spicy to tell them stories rather than
some boring man in a suit does it prompt
too many questions though of a
sexualized nature I mean there is a
whole debate in America in particularly
Florida Governor DeSantis there and
others believing you just shouldn't have
anything
sexualized going on in in Young School
classrooms I can assure you the drag
story times in Britain have no sex
whatsoever it's just simply a man in
drag telling stories like anybody else
would wholesome innocent stories family
stories and often the parents come along
as well and the reports I've heard from
parents is they are delighted that these
drag queens have managed to get their
kids interested in Reading
appears you would have taken your kids
to see panto when they were younger I'm
sure and Lord knows I grew up loving Mrs
Doubtfire and I've turned out just fine
peers
um I think that the problem is we get
this cultural hangover from the states a
lot of the time of course there are the
odd pictures of people doing the
backward splits and all that where I'm
not sure that that's the type of
performance that we're describing when
we're making a defensive drag queen
story well let me ask let me ask Lauren
on that point I mean Mrs doubtfar was a
hugely popular movie did that offend you
would you watch that with a child if so
what's the real difference
well I think there's a very important
distinction to be made between
cross-dressing and specifically drag and
I I have to say I think your guests are
aware of this difference the history of
drag is very rooted in sexualized
performances the person who kind of
pioneered drag queen Story Hour
specifically talks about using drag in
order to subvert the nuclear family
heteronormativity and in order to
implant I guess Notions of queerness in
children's brains so I'm sorry but no I
simply don't believe that this is just
about getting kids to read there are so
many different ways that we could have
initiatives to encourage literacy among
children none of which involved adult
men wearing prosthetic breasts which is
exactly what drag is well ultimately and
maybe there may be a slight cultural
difference between Britain and America
on this because the panto culture is so
prevalent here and it isn't in America
so it might be I just want to also Adams
very quickly even in a society where
everything is offensive including a
white person wearing dreadlocks why is
it okay why is it celebrated for grown
men to be essentially wearing Woman face
and Performing all these caricatures of
female sensitivity
you're offended by it
well I think it's hypocritical for these
people who are often on the left
sorry offensiveness
are you offended I wouldn't I I am
offended of this happening in front of
children yes that does offend me very
much listen I've got to leave it there
thank you very much indeed uh thank you
both very much indeed thanks uh we
appreciate it coming next Boris Johnson
breaks his silence and everybody wishes
he hadn't
foreign
[Music]
they're careful doing crane too exactly
this is like some kind of Submarine
prime minister he isn't making the case
you're making the case here now I think
you did kill these women because they
need Justice you did kill them didn't
you
what we're all Races we're all sexist
World home
[Music]
thank you
history is littered with a long line of
lovable but Angry Men
I don't believe it but one man rises
above them all what just happened
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
well coming up on the talk further fall
out from those lockdown files as new
leaked WhatsApp messages show cabinet
conflict over lockdowns and school
closures during the pandemic and MI5
apologizes after an inquiry says it
missed a significant opportunity to stop
the Manchester Arena bombing and should
prisoners be used to pick crops all of
that and more at nine
the best read we've had
welcome back Isabel Richard quick wrap
up here Boris Johnson broke his sinus
today to try and stick the knife in the
Rishi sunak and his and his plan for
getting brexit actually done I just
don't want Boris Johnson to break his
silence I'm going to shut up now and go
away I think half the country wants that
but look the reality is he sees an
opportunity he's been carefully
assessing what he should do when he
should speak it's becoming clear that
more and more people uh in Northern
Ireland unionists probably the dup Lord
Frost yesterday Boris coming out today
are saying actually Rishi has completely
Miss sold this deal with the EU if you
read the eu's documents it's a com it's
almost like a completely different deal
to what Richard in the end Isabel the
bottom line of this most people whatever
side they were on they just want this
over with right and if it means a little
bit more compromise and they're prepared
to stomach then so be it I just think
Boris trying to do what he's doing On
Maneuvers trying to stiff Rishi how does
it help anybody well it was ever thus as
Boris he's been doing this for the last
15 years hasn't he and I agree with you
that most people just they didn't really
understand it if they don't live in
Northern Ireland or the Republic and
they just want it to go away
um and I'm not spread look it was a
communication Triumph for Richie sunac
the small print as ever doesn't match up
but most people are not going to be too
upset by that exactly exactly well thank
you both of you you must have had an
interesting few months you too knowing
about this bomb about to go off so I
appreciate you both it's sparing me
timing your busy schedules tonight
that's it for me what are you up to Keep
It Uncensored good night
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Laughter]
prime minister he isn't making the case
you're making the case here now I think
you did kill these women because they
need Justice you did kill them didn't
you
what we're already says we're all sexist
World homophobia
[Music]
thank you
cookies
history is littered with a long line of
lovable but Angry Men
finally my stupidity pays off I don't
believe it but one man rises above them
all what